“The Great Migration”
Where’s the forty acres & a mule
in the long, great getting-up
morning?
Sharecroppers asked the sun
hidden by cotton & pulpwood.
Hawkish agents
from the northern factories
trekked into Jim Crow twilight
between promise & no way
as farmers questioned soil
under fingernails, the knowhow
of dreaming in the hot shine
of blast furnaces up there.
They crossed lines drawn in dust,
huddled in trains racing trees.
Blues hitched a ride, washed out
of overalls & jumpers, threadbare suits
& floral dresses, & cotton-sack gowns
bleached translucent by runagate
skies at noontime.
As the trains
jostled
along winding tracks, tales
of the North Star & rivers to cross
unstitched beneath heavy eyelids
till the electric hum of big cities
shone under the night’s hardscrabble.
A tug of the line,
a fish story on the hook
snagged. The steel mills, foundry smoke
& hiss, stockyards, packing houses,
Rock Island Mine an unending song
unwound like a spool of red thick
thread
in the sluggish dawn.
Someone carried the pattern
of squares & triangles hand sewn
into a circle & passed down.
The unborn rode the rail for free.
Some could still see the sanctified
taken down to the muddy river.
Cuttings, sprigs, & potato vines,
took root in half-gallon tin cans
facing the sooty south windows.
How could any of their children
dream themselves into doctors,
and lawyers in cold water flats?
Ragged tunes in their heads flowered
in all-night cabarets & speakeasies
up & down the eastern seaboard.
Shellshock & mustard gas in trenches
followed home some soldiers
who danced the lindy hop
with the newcomers,
while others
called them breakers,
as work
took another life in the words
of poor man porters & superheroes
in the movies or on the radio,
forgetting the twelve-foot long
cotton sacks,
as they strolled down
tree-lined boulevards & avenues,
& ghosts from the old country
hung out on street corners
drawn in the drifting harangue
of field hollers in the snow.